You talk about family a lot in your book,
and apparently your mom watches the show.
Let me tell you,
Mammers tells me that she watches your show
basically every day.
I talk to her pretty much every day on FaceTime
and everyday she reminds me how much she loves you,
how great you are, how cute you are, how positive you are.
She loves your show, it like uplifts her,
she gets her coffee, she starts calling people,
but she's like a Drew Barrymore stan.
She loves you.
(Drew screaming)
Gosh, I'm so excited.
Well let's bring her in, welcome everybody, Denise Rapinoe.
(crowd cheering)
Hi Denise!
Hi.
I'm so honored that you watch the show, I'm so glad.
Love your show, love it.
It's so awesome.
You have so much joy.
It's just been the best thing ever
since pandemic, definitely.
(Drew screaming)
Oh, I'm looking around,
'cause that's just, we all appreciate that so much
and that's what we're trying to do here,
acknowledge reality, but get into the good stuff.
And you do, completely.
We gotta have some joy.
I find optimism without reality
is sort of like not my bag anymore.
I think I used to be into that,
but now it's like,
how do we acknowledge the world
and yet find our own way in it together?
So I would love to do a rapid fire question
with you, Denise, about Megan,
because I just find these unorthodox questions
so much more revealing than the traditional ones,
and we're going to do it in under well a minute ish,
I'm a Pisces and I have no time management
so we're going to do Megan in a minute.
(crowd cheering)
(upbeat pop music)
Okay, ready?
The first person Megan calls when she gets good news.
Sue.
Sue? Aww.
Okay, what was Megan likely to get in trouble for at school?
Probably talking too much in class.
Oh, that's fun and not so bad after all.
Yeah, I was like, it's fine.
I'm just having a conversation,
don't worry about it, teacher.
Yeah, I'm like if that's your biggest problem,
that's not so bad.
Okay, who's posters did Megan have on her walls as a kid?
Michael Jordan, Mia Hamm, Michelle Akers.
I had Superman, Debbie Harry and Kiss.
Okay, one chore Megan always hated.
Well cleaning your bedroom,
but really all chores, all chores.
It's true. (all laughing)
She had bigger fish to fry.
Okay, do you remember the first movie Megan watched?
Everything Disney and then everything Jim Carrey.
Okay, Dumb and Dumber is a masterpiece,
it should be number one on the AFI top 100.
Megan's favorite meal as a kid?
Chicken and dumplings.
Ooh, that just made me so hungry.
Megan, how do you feel your mom got those, right?
Yeah, I think she pretty much nailed everything.
You were really paying attention when I was a child.
(audience clapping)
Oh, very much so.
Yeah.
I love mothers and daughters.
I feel like that is my emotional journey in this world,
the big part of my destiny and it is just,
I now have two daughters, you know,
a lot of my life was sort of being my own mother,
working out things with my mom,
I love so much of the things she did
and then I had to learn how to do things differently
at the same time and you know,
the bond and the relationship
and the journey between mothers and daughters
is just, it's what I know, it's what I've experienced
and it is all about the human condition and the heart.
And I love your guys's relationship.
It's been so fun to delve into your life
and your family and your journey
and it's just been so joyous and empowering and inspiring.
And I love that you guys are so close
and the Mammers had too,
and just everything, I celebrate you both
and I'm so, I feel so lucky that you came on this show.
Thank you for being here today. (audience cheering)
Thank you for having us, so wonderful.
And thank you for everything you put out into the world.
Your strength is very inspiring
and people watch it and then they live their own life,
you know, with that in mind
so it's extremely important and thank you so much,
Megan and Denise, One Life is available right now.
(upbeat pop music)